hello if you live in strasbourg
and that you are dedicated to the animal cause
then you will probably be interested in my video
I introduce myself
my name is deboragoulé
I am 22 years old
and I am a candidate for the legislative elections
for the animalist party
and I represent constituency 2 of Strasbourg
I will need help with this campaign
if I make this video today
it's because I need volunteers
who are dedicated to animals
who want to sensitize the population of Strasbourg
strasbourge strasbourgeoise
to the animal cause
and who would be willing to help me to pull off
and speak in public
for these legislative elections
if you are interested
do not hesitate to send your application in quotation marks
to the email address that I will display right here
by specifying your first name your name your age
your experience
your skills and motivation
see you soon I hope